Okay.
No, this is not a drill guys, this is the second live of the day, you are correct.
Yeah, this is how far we go for you guys are rock star student today is from Australia, so he was gracious enough to jump on and it is right now 7am.
In the land down under, so I'm going to have Levi jump on in just a second here and share he is definitely trailblazing over 40 closes over 15 active rank and rank legions this guy has already done enough rinse and repeat.
He's definitely an og so let's see here without further ado, let me start the recording and then get Levi in.
Okay.
I can also check the volume and the sound. Can you guys let me know if you can hear me.
I want to make sure that this new mic is doing its job.
Okay.
Okay, we are live in the right group. Good.
And I can see myself.
Hey Levi.
How's it going buddy.
Good.
Good. Are you caffeinated.
No, I don't drink coffee. Oh wow, you're just get up and go huh. Yeah, this role role.
All right.
I'm impressed.
So, for those who don't know you Levi, can you tell everyone.
When you got into the space and how it came about, what happened, how did you find yourself in this program.
How I found myself in this program I think someone told me about the group. I think I checked it out. And then I found out he's got a paid course and I'll just jumped right into it.
I skipped all the free stuff and just went straight into it.
I just, I don't know if it's me being lazy or I just, I'll value something a lot more if I put money into it, and I see a better return faster, because it's like I have to make this work.
Rather than doing the free stuff, you kind of skim on by and I'm sure there's a lot of guys out there that would just keep skimming on by and they don't actually take that action to get something started.
Back in 2022, this one I joined.
Yeah, it's like, what is the same, nothing wagered nothing gained, like you put your money where your mouth is, and you keep yourself accountable that way if it's just a free course like, you know, take it or leave it but when you're paying for it, you kind of
make it work to use it.
Yeah, that's a good way to explain it. Yeah, so you jumped on immediately in 2022. And did you start running through the process or did you set it aside and go do something else did you did you dive right in right into it.
I think it was like day 29 or something I got my first deal. And then it was pretty much near like a month after that I think I've got another deal and then a couple months after that I've got another deal and it just kept kind of going from there.
Wow, that's awesome.
Yeah, so you, you definitely don't write in then it took me a while to close a rank and rank deal. I've done so much other stuff when I started.
It took over a year to close anything that has to do with the lead generation or rank and rank so yeah that tells me you really focus like you did not get distracted, and you just hammered that process over and over, rinsed and repeated.
Yeah, so many phone calls, which is good, because that first client is still with me to this day.
Do you care to share the niche.
Oh, really. Yeah, nice. Are you getting volume are you getting enough volume. Yeah, probably.
If we go back during like peak season we'll get like 500 leads coming through in one month.
Good Lord. Wow. Yeah, it was up there.
Yeah, you're definitely compensated with the volume.
Yeah, because it is low ticket just like here right like lawn mowing would be, first of all, reoccurring so when you get an account it's like, it keeps paying so that's a good thing.
But it is low ticket you're looking at, I don't know, 50 bucks every time they do it or something like that here, I just paid $200 to get my yard mode.
Yep. And yeah, it depends. It depends where you live. So for me I pay $150 for the entire month. Yeah, that is awesome that it is expensive over there so it makes sense and the fact that it would be quite like you're quite periods of during, I guess, winter when nothing grows but then right now where it's raining every couple days, the grass is shooting up and the guys are loving it.
Yep. Oh, I believe it. Yeah, when you have that sun rain sun rain, the grass just goes crazy. We have that here too in Florida.
During the summer where you can't keep up with the with the grass anymore. It just goes wild. I love that man so you had this guy this whole time. How does he do when things get scarce like, does he freak out or is he cool with it.
We've gone through, like, I don't know if you call it rough patches where he's caught up saying he wants to cancel.
And it was just a simple matter of just talking and figuring out what's going on and we're able to work something out came to an agreement whether
I'll reduce the payment for a little bit for like, I don't know a month I think I said, but then after that I'm going to increase them. And I think I ended up increasing it, but it's not like a massive paying client like I think it's only like six hundred bucks a month or something.
But yeah, I just I increased it pretty much a little bit from there, and I'll probably end up increasing it again soon ish. He understands he sees the value in it now. A lot of his clients aren't even residential just all the commercial jobs that come through.
So he's got a couple of the commercial jobs and they're like 3k a month and he only goes there. Maybe once a weekend in a month. And you'll do that. There's got a few of those that come through.
Yeah, I mean, he's definitely getting a great deal with you. Is this all organic?
Yeah, all organic now. Yep. Beautiful. Beautiful. It was my first ever site I ever built ever ranked ever did anything with.
Yeah, that's awesome man.
Yeah, I definitely see you increasing your price with him. You just have to nurture him. You know, every year he's going to get more and more convinced that this is this is what he needs.
And I like that he already went through a couple of seasonality cycles. So he knows what the low looks like and what the high looks like.
So yeah, once he, you know, puts all his numbers and goes through his numbers and stuff, he'll he will see that there's a return on investment.
So yeah, your service definitely makes sense to him, especially with the crazy volume you're getting him. That's a $2,000 a month website.
Yeah, it's just a matter of bringing him up there little by little. Every year you can, you know, you can.
As he grows, I'm able to increase the price pretty much as I've gone with anyone, any businesses as they grow that business, I'm able to increase my prices and we can scale it together.
Especially that you get him commercial. That's that's no joke, because if you're paying a couple hundred dollars to to mow a residential, I mean, to mow commercial that's that's a lot more.
And if he just does one commercial job a month that covers for your fee, you know, four or five times over. So yeah, I like it, man.
I like it, man. So you've done the lawn mowing and then you you created you had momentum right after that first deal, you stayed on.
Yeah, kept on. I did the whole let's run five different ad campaigns at the same time and burn myself out really quick.
Yeah, I think everyone's kind of done that.
Um, let my lesson really quick, choose through your money really fast when you're not able to pay attention to every single job coming through.
And you kind of start from the wrong foot where I never had any any list built out. So I didn't know who to contact when these jobs came through.
So I was just all up in the air. That screwed me over a little bit.
And eventually, I think at the right timing to I just canceled, I think, four or three other of the ads out of the five, and I only had one or two running.
And then from that one or two, I was able to just kind of focus on those two and get a client for that and I was in the concrete niche.
Nice. And concrete niche is good in Australia. Is it like a like a year year round thing?
Everything is yearly, like it's all everything in Australia is all year round. I have yet to find something that's not.
Deck building is probably the only thing that's like a yearly like a that that's seasonal. I think everything else is is all year round. I think yeah decking and pool builds.
I would imagine are the only two things that are seasonal.
That's awesome that so Australia is prime for for rank and rent then and because oh yeah you have you guys have the four seasons in one day situation right like you get in rain and sun and so but but it doesn't freeze right.
No, no, no cold.
Down south, there's a little bit of cold and on some mountain peaks you might get snow but I would say 98% of Australia is not like this. There's no snow. Yeah, my knowledge.
I like that I mean a lot of it is an uninhabited and you know Bush and desert and all that stuff but when you go to a populated area, you can run a rank and rent and run it no issues, no seasonality issues or anything for the most part.
Yeah, I like that and concrete is one of them because concrete takes a beating.
It, you know, it expands and it contracts and the sun the water. So yeah, Australia should be prime for concrete because there's a lot of erosion, concrete erosion going on cracks and all that stuff in Australian weather is a little rough like especially the heat, it gets pretty, pretty crazy right.
Well, I think, what was it yesterday was like, see I don't know what it is in Fahrenheit but it was 31 or 32 degrees Celsius it was 8% or 90% humidity. It was like 42 degrees so I think that's in the 90s, I think, and yeah, yeah.
What is it 31 centigrade.
Okay, so it feels like 107 Fahrenheit.
Holy smokes.
Yeah, that's an oven. Okay.
I see why it works.
That's awesome. What other niches or niches can you share with us that were successful other than lawn mowing and concrete.
Anything and everything really like as long as you give it a go.
I've heard guys get, I'm not in roofing but I know people that have been in roofing.
Deck building.
The volumes not there though with deck building sometimes fencing bathroom remodels.
What else we got I'm trying to think off the top of my head.
Landscapers.
There's a few, I'm pretty just stuck with fencing and concrete, like the other two that I'm in.
Oh, okay, nice. Fencing is good too.
Yeah, yeah.
Fencing and concrete. Okay.
Nice. So, what, how do you see yourself, handling the deals now versus when you started, what, what has changed since
I don't think so.
Same process.
I've probably adjusted a little bit, but nothing crazy like if you compare what Nick teaches and what I do, it's, I'd say it's very similar, you'll be able to compare like apples for apples almost.
Right. So you're not getting creative, you're just sticking to it.
Yeah, I try and keep my basic.
I don't want to overcomplicate stuff but I'd rather keep it nice and simple and just go with that.
Yeah, I have I have complicated things before and it backfired.
I have freestyled the script before I have done the screen recording differently I've done did things differently and sometimes it works and sometimes it backfires.
I do go off script, when I have like an existing client, like we just I just closed one yesterday and they're already. He was already a client of mine we were doing other stuff like other marketing stuff.
And then we discovered that we could do rank and rent for them. So that one I didn't go through the entire thing. I just sent them, you know, two or three and they're like yeah this is good.
And we have done a call yesterday for like 15 minutes and that was it just a bit more than me, I'll just send him a text message and we just both give each other a thumbs up and go from there.
Really you've done that before you close that way.
Yeah, yeah, we'll just send a text message and just get all right this is what we do. This is how much it costs. Sweet.
Like a friend or family. No, no, just a client that I've probably had for a year now.
Yep. He went from, what was he paying? He was paying like $1,600 a month. Now he's doing paying me $1,000 a week.
Sweet. That's good. That's four grand a month.
I like it. And you, you told me off camera that you are in the, you were in the 40,000s and now that you lost a couple of clients recently, you are in the 30s and the mid 30s. Is that accurate?
Yeah, 25, 30s around there. I would say I'm just kind of waiting to see how it all ends up and go from there.
Yep. That's pretty impressive though. And the fact that you did that in two years, that is, that shows consistency for sure.
Yeah, a lot of those clients will come back on in the new year. It's just personal reasons. I know some had health reasons, but they've hurt their back, they've hurt their foot.
Being as like a, just a, the business being dependent on them, I guess that's like, we call them sole traders. It's hard for them. So obviously with those issues, they've obviously paused, cancelled, I guess over this Christmas period.
And then they said, look, once we're all better, once we're all on top of things, we'll continue on in the new year.
Right. Yeah, you will get a lot of those now because they're trying to save some money, like a couple of weeks.
I've had a couple call up and I just straight up told them that we just continue on through and it's what everyone else is doing. Just continue on through because you're still going to get jobs coming through.
The jobs don't stop coming through. We're still getting jobs coming through to this day. Like I've already had emails come through now, like one, two, two couple jobs there just now in the past two minutes, three minutes.
So it's not like there's no shortage of work coming through. It's consistently paying. So it's not like you're paying for something and you're getting nothing. You're going to be getting jobs coming through, I would dare say, up to Christmas.
It will stop on Christmas and then continue on after that and then stop on New Year's and then continue after that.
Yeah, I mean, that's a great argument. That's a great way to put it. Like the leads don't stop. Yes, you do want to take a break during Christmas and not pay for a week or two, but or you can just schedule in January and still go to your Christmas party.
Have them there and then contact them when you get back. People are contacting you knowing that you're on holidays. It's not like they don't think you're on holidays. It's just they know that you're busy, you're on holidays, you'll get to them when you get to them.
And if you can contact them, you basically by putting yourself out there, you got that opportunity to then contact them later on. Otherwise, you never get that opportunity. If they cancel now, it means they don't get that lead.
And now that they're starting off on a bad foot, because now they've got to wait for more leads to come through. Rather than keeping that pipeline full, they empty the pipeline.
Yes, yes. That's a great argument. Yeah, hitting the ground running once January comes and you're like, you're not shutting down and then come January, like waking up like, oh, let's start over.
So when businesses cancel, they want to pause. I highly suggest not doing it because of the like, you may save like a couple of dollars, but it costs you a lot more in the long run because you go from having a consistent flow of jobs coming through and you'll consistently smash them out. You may not be making great money. You may think, oh, I need to cancel this for a month while I've got a month booked out. But then as soon as that month ends, you're like, fuck, I've got no more jobs.
And when you start learning jobs, it's not going to be straight away. There's, I think on average three to six weeks is what it takes to land a client is what I found just based on talking to my clients. That's three to six weeks of no work that they have coming through.
And now, now they're, that's a whole month where they're not making any money and they're having to pay me. So it sucks. You'd rather make a little bit than make nothing.
Yeah, that puts it into perspective. Like what you're working on today, you will close in a couple of weeks. You're not just going to start in January and start closing right away. You got to nurture the job. So why not keep the wheel turning, not pause.
What I use as an argument also, in addition to that, and you can use this is I tell them, I can't pause Google. I'm not going to pause Google because if I pause it, I'm going to get penalized and I'm going to start over. I've got to season the ad again. I've got to go through all that BS.
So I told them, I'm going to have to find someone else. I respect your decision, but I'm going to have to find someone else to pick up slack because I don't want to go through this again. I can't pause the ad. And that's when they realized, oh, okay, this is not up to us. It's we need to stick with this. This is not like a picky choosy, you know, take it or leave it.
I want to use it kind of thing. It's a right. Yeah, we're paying Google top dollar. You're in you need to have some skin in the game. Absolutely. But I like your argument for sure. Because yeah, you can't you don't just pause and then hit the ground running in January like you got to.
You got to go through a little bit of tumbling before you before you stand up.
I like it. What is what is the most deals that that you got canceled on like what is what is the worst cancellation streak you had for me it was, I think, three, three in a row in like two weeks.
Probably seven in the past month and a half. Yeah, that one stings man. Yeah, I had to have some hard conversations with some of the clients because and this is every year I think I need to find like a permanent solution is because as soon as Thanksgiving is over, everyone wants to take a break everyone wants to take a nap.
Everyone wants to stop being charged. And the conversation that I always bring is, do you remember, June and July when we were blowing it up.
You didn't ask you didn't ask to cancel then.
And I didn't ask you for more money.
When we were doing really well but now that we're trickling one to a week.
I see that you want to cancel.
This is not what I had in mind when I said a mutually beneficial relationship. This is not what I had in mind when we talked about a win win situation.
I can't give you all the upside and take all the downside, otherwise I'll be out of business so I do blow it up for you in June and July.
I don't want enough cash to justify going through the slow season.
So that's the conversation that I have with them, and a lot of them get it. Actually, a lot of them understand.
But I tell the other ones, if you want to cancel on that, I'm not going to hire a lawyer for $4,000 to go up to come after $4,000 that's not what I'm, but I'm what I'm going to do is I'm going to go find someone else.
If I go back, I'm probably going to be hooked up with someone else and I don't want you to be in that situation where you need me and I'm already engaged with someone else.
And that they get it that way like oh okay so this is like he's not going to pause just because I want to pause he's going to go find someone else, my competitor, I don't want that.
Yeah, or I think any client that's cancelled understands that. Like I said, there's been a couple like from that seven, maybe half will probably sign up again in the new year.
So I'm not too stressed about it. Obviously they're off, they're not paying or anything, but they're going to continue on in the new year.
The other four or so I think one just called me up saying he's too stressed out from the amount of work, which is to be expected when he's just a solo guy, he hasn't fired anyone.
I always expect it for those guys. I'm the one taking the risk on them. If I do go with them and usually they'll sell me and they're like yeah please like let's do this.
When I'm telling them no, I don't think this is going to work out. They're the ones that are like yeah let's do this, let's do this, like I'll work really hard, I'll make this work.
Some get it and it clicks for them and they do really well. Others, it just doesn't click fast enough or they're not able to withstand that pressure of all the stress coming through and I don't sugarcoat any of this shit at all.
I would rather tell them straight up that it's going to stress you out. You're going to feel like the world's going to end and you're probably going to want to quit on this and you end up closing down your business if you do quit on it.
Everyone goes through this feeling, it's just a matter of pushing through it and if you can withstand that push through. If you can't withstand that push through, don't even bother starting too much.
I'd rather you not start, you don't waste either of our time where if you're willing to push through this shit and get through all the crap, all the bullshit, all the headaches, the stress of the clients, the stress of clients not paying your money,
the stress of me coming after you for money, like you having to pay me weekly or monthly or whatever, the stress of just being up late and everything. If you can get through all that on the other side, it's awesome. It's just you got to get through that shit bit to get to the good bit.
Yes, absolutely. Go through the shit bit to get to the good bit. Yes. Let's see, I have another question for you here.
To go through that, I'll expand on that. I've had a client that shared with me recently, he was telling me how for a period that he was basically collecting cans, like 10 cent cans and given them and collecting the money for that and that's what he was using to feed his family for a little bit.
Because all his money was invested straight into the business. Wow. Fast forward now that guy's paying me $1,000 a week and he's doing really well. One of the jobs I think he's got is like $2.8 million or something like that. It's like 40 projects that are like 60 grand each.
60 projects that are 40 grand each. Wow. That's crazy. So this guy is like textbook entrepreneur. Yeah, he's done well. It's not his first business. He sold cans to fund the business.
I don't know if you have it in the US or not, but it's like a recycling initiative where you can collect your beer bottle cans and stuff and you give them in. So that's what he was doing just to put some food on the table for his family because all his money was invested in jobs and he didn't have much to do.
Yeah, that's a gangster move right there. Going above and beyond for your business. You mentioned people complaining about too much business like they freak out when there's like too much influx.
I used to not have an answer for that, but I drafted something and I started using it because it is a BS excuse. That's probably the worst excuse I hear is you're sending me too much.
Like that's the point is blowing it up for you as opposed to having really scarce leads. So what I tell them is I don't see a problem. If you can't help them now, schedule them out. If they want to move on and go somewhere else, they can go somewhere else.
You can take the ones that make the most sense to you and say no to the ones that you don't and outsource them and that way you're raising your price. You're doing less work and you're raising your prices and making more money.
So I don't get that. I don't get the, oh, you're sending me too much. I can't handle it. Yes, you can say no to 40% and say yes to 60% and raise your prices.
So yeah, that's what I've been saying to that because it pissed me off and I didn't have an answer until like a year ago or something like that.
I've never had to really say it because a lot of the guys, at least the ones that I've been qualifying correctly and going through the whole process and they just click like some guys just get the whole process and it clicks for them and all they need is more work and that's like the final piece of the puzzle for them.
Other guys need to go through a few more steps to get them to understand but the guys that understand it, they're increasing their prices. They know right now around Christmas time they're increasing their prices for anyone that wants it done ASAP.
Anyone that wants any project done before Christmas, it's going to cost you an extra 20% more if you want to get it done.
Other guys like the guy that pays me $1,000 a week because he's got a couple different locations now. Some of those locations like the newer locations that he's not fully developed in, he's dropped his prices just to get more jobs coming through, books up a team and then he'll increase the prices.
The areas where he's already established those prices are probably I'd say 20% more than everyone else because he knows the value of what he's doing.
That's smart. Yeah, I mean that's a smart way to go about it instead of trying to jump on every job that we send and freaking out if you don't get it or whatever. Yeah, whatever. You're paying a flat fee so focus on quality not the volume.
Let me take care of the volume. You focus on quality, taking the stuff that makes the most sense to you, the most money and just dumping the rest.
I've had that with my epoxy guy. He does not do epoxy countertops. He only does epoxy floors because he's past that. He used to do it, but now it's not good money.
Yeah, it's not worth his time so now he says no to countertops and outsource them over to his nephew, cousin, whatever.
What's that? How is epoxy? I've never gone into it. I haven't looked into it too hard either. Yeah, it's great because it, first of all, it's a luxury item so it's something that people want, they fancy.
It's not like your toilet just broke and you're pissed off and you just want a plumber to come and fix it because there's shit everywhere, but for epoxy it's like, oh, I want to look at colors.
So it's a luxury item and it's usually $3,500, $5,500 all the way up to $8,000 depending on how fancy or how durable you want it and that makes the ticket price, that makes it worth it.
So if you can just get someone 15 calls a month, that makes a huge difference in their business. If you get them 15, they close 10. That's 40 grand or 50 grand just like that a month.
So if you can start there and then build up and go horizontal or go vertical, you can really make a difference in their business.
So yeah, we've done it successfully in multiple big cities, but now I'm trying to go obscure city because all the big cities are saturated obviously, they have dumped so much ad money.
So now we're going to obscure cities to get the most bang for the buck.
Auto referral for it. I just haven't, like from an old client referred it to me. I just haven't done anything with it just yet.
Just watch that ad, watch the CPC in the ad. It is a luxury item so it might be comparable to roofing, it might be comparable to paint, like a house painting, and it could cost you big pretty quick.
But yeah, it's successful all the time. If you can find a low enough hang in fruit, it will be a successful campaign.
Yeah.
I don't know if we have any questions yet. I can't see them on my computer so I have to open my phone.
Do you guys have any questions?
Let's see.
No, no comments. Oh, here we go. Jean.
Hi, Jean. Jean Clinton, Jean Lenton and Luke Pichard are watching. I appreciate you guys jumping on.
Nick Wood says, two of the big dogs with a money bag next to it. Yes, we are big dogs and we're making money bags, sir.
Learn from the best, Nick. Learn from the best.
All right. Let's see what else do they want to talk to you about. Oh, yes. What is, you've experienced the churn burn. Now, what is that? Do you have a strategy to mitigate that and stay on top of it?
Because it is heartbreaking, man. I've been through these cancellations and they are the most stressful.
Yeah, it used to get to me. Doesn't as much anymore. I think of it as a good thing in a way now, where if they're leaving, it means the ones that are staying are willing to go that extra mile and the ones that are dropping off, they just weren't able to keep up as we continue to grow.
I'd rather have that spot open and find someone else than have it filled with someone that's only putting in 50%. I'd rather them drop off and then find someone that's willing to put in 100% and go that extra 100, like that extra 10% and go 110% to get to that extra mile.
So that's how I kind of think about it now.
It's, I guess the age old saying like it is what it is, like there's not much I can do about it. I got a lot of these times, if they drop off, it's either they've just completely gone ghost and just vanished off the face of the earth.
I've learned not to do deals with young people that are into drugs. So I'm not doing that anymore.
How did you pick up on that?
I saw it on Facebook.
I'm friends with, I got friends with a couple of them on Facebook and yeah, I saw one of the blokes that just disappeared on me and I saw him on Facebook, he started talking about mushrooms and everything.
So I was like, I went on like a little mushroom trip and redeveloped the world or something. Nothing against it. It's just, it was young,
None of them mix well together, pretty much. I think that calls for a recipe for disaster. A couple guys, I think I later on realized they had like a criminal record and sometimes it's worked out fine and they've been awesome.
Other time they've just gone on to start stealing from customers and it's just a, all right, cut off, nothing to do with you. Any customers that ring up, here's their contact details.
That's crazy because I had exact examples. I had a con, who I didn't know was a con, just, you know, wreak havoc, you know, taking deposits and running away and all that stuff, right?
You know, just shady contractor stuff. And then I had another one who came up to me clean the first time that we talked and I had just closed him.
And he called me and said, hey, I need to tell you something. I am this and this and this. And he went through his criminal record and he said, I need to be upfront with you. I was into this. I was into this.
And he was, we just parted ways actually. He was one of my best clients for like three years. But he just moved in a different direction now.
But he came to me and he just said, hey, I need to discuss something with you. This is what I've been into. I have turned my life and that is why I changed my last name. This was my last name. Now it is this because, you know, the federal whatever.
But yeah, he was amazing. He was a great, great businessman. And then the other guy was the complete opposite, just a shade. He's never been to the prison, but he was a con for sure. You could like he's been to jail.
He hasn't been to prison, but he's been to jail and he's been has been in courts before and stuff. So yeah, yeah. I mean, those those guys exist and I, I appreciate you mentioning it because you've got to sniff out that stuff.
And that's why we do our due diligence. That's why we make create those lists and we have the profile, Facebook profile of the owner of the company so we know who we're talking to.
You create that avatar in your brain as you're talking to them. Yeah, all this stuff is relevant, especially when it comes to these situations where you're dealing with a young and silly person, an immature person, a con.
He's doing well. Like he was doing 20, 30 K a month, like I think I'm not just by profit for his business. So he was doing good. It's just, yeah, obviously when you mix substance and business and try and do it all together.
Yeah, distraction.
Nothing works out pretty much.
Yeah.
I've had clients just a lot of it's just been personal reasons which is out of my control out of their control, whether it's it's family related whether it's injury related and that's like I guess the biggest thing is injury related when it's when they're still on the tools and they get injured, it screws them up big time.
That's probably the biggest thing that causes for the downturn and I guess loss of a lot of clients.
Probably and then stress, stress is like another big one, and I guess you can kind of call that under personal but it's a bit of, are you willing to push through that shit and go through it.
And I've had some that are stubborn and don't listen when I try and help them out. I've had some that when I say you need to fire this client, or it's like fire this employee.
They don't fire them and it ends up buying them in the ass.
And I could just tell, because I've been through I've listened to other guys tell me this exact conversation.
And that's that's something I've realized now like getting sidetracked a little bit is every single business owner is going through the exact same shit so some guys are here some guys are here but they're on that same path.
And this person here has been through what this person he is going through. So, what I do often is I'll just talk to this person and say what did you do in this situation, and then pass that knowledge on to this person here, because this person's already gone through it,
they've been through that shit they've gone through the headaches and everything they've dealt with those shitty employees. And then this person is just this is their first time going through it.
So I give them that little bit of guidance.
Sometimes I'll even put them in contact with each other so they can just talk to each other and brainstorm different ideas out and solve a lot of issues I've had some clients that went from.
I don't know they couldn't land any deals, and I put them in contact with this other guy who kind of had that drama at one stage, they are talking now is landing deals and he booked out for months.
So, that's, that's kind of my biggest, I guess, role now is just connecting the new guys with the experienced guys that I, I haven't have my contacts now. So I'm an old client some existing clients like it's not just like my existing clients a lot of my old clients
are still happy to help me out and help help out other guys, it's just, they've moved in a different direction for whatever reason.
Yeah.
Now that's that's a great like connecting them shortcuts the process instead of you showing them how it's done. You show them a business that's almost like a clone of theirs, and they can just copy and paste and swipe all the, you know, the CRM stuff like, yeah, I actually dealt with
business owners who do not use the CRM which is crazy. Not even a spreadsheet. I think maybe two of mine do.
Yeah, not even a spreadsheet they just go with their text messages and call and they just store everything here which is super I try and get everyone on a calendar at least create a calendar and use the calendar, and your notepad on your phone.
Yeah, if you want to do stuff use that, because I go, what's called like a diary it just becomes too complicated when you scroll through pages for at least if it's on your calendar you can have a look and see them and they're what's going on.
Yeah, yeah, agree.
Do you have touch points with these business owners do you do you call them or text them often.
Not really like at the start will be in contact but I'm trying to think like there's a client that I close probably like a couple weeks ago now, like those two are probably contacted them once or twice, and it's been maybe three weeks.
I think I contacted them obviously when we first spoke, and then I contacted them. Once I got like, like once I started sending the jobs through you can say, I got them all set up so it's all automatic.
That's probably the only two times I've contacted them.
Other guys, I think I've contacted he's probably been with me for two months now probably contacted him twice or three times.
That's just like how they are with their business, some guys are contacts, and other guys, I can kind of just let them go, a lot of my older clients.
I'm. I want to say I haven't contacted them for like six months but in reality I probably contacted them like at least once a month, just not knowing it that that little mine client.
I think there was a stage there where I didn't contact him for like eight months.
We just we just caught up because he's in the same town as me so we just caught up went out for lunch, had a chat, went over things and continued on from there.
If possible, that's what I try and do is catch up with clients in person. It's, it's an easier way to know who they are because people can let off a certain side of them over a video call over a phone call, whatever it is but when you look at them in person you shake the
hands you look them in the eyes. It's a dead giveaway and that's how I found out one of my clients was going to leave me just from didn't have to say anything, but just him in the eyes shaking his hand seeing what he's doing at work.
And just knowing that eventually he's going to cut off and lo and behold he cut off but ended up starting to work with one of his ex employees who ended up going out in his own.
So, funny how it works. Yeah, you can tell a lot by meeting people in person and I think they appreciate catching up with people in, in, in person as well. Like I've caught up or going out to events with a few of them now and we've hung out, and I've went out like to like a, like a bull ride, and like them their kids, one of their employees their family they all came out and we all had a good time.
That's awesome. Yeah, the personal thing for sure I'm still trying it.
I do have clients all over the US so I can't get into a personal meeting with all of them but the local ones. I definitely tried, and I got a couple of them but not all of them, a lot of them just resist it.
Yeah, happy just keeping it transactional, and that's it. And others are like, I thought the same, and give it some time and they'll flip around is what I found. So I had one guy that just didn't really want to communicate and just kind of left it as is.
And now I was like, oh look, I'll come down, we'll catch up, and we'll hang out for a little bit and he's a bit more open to it now. He was, I don't know six months ago when it was like three months into the contract kind of thing.
Yeah.
Like, when, when they want to cancel when when things slow down and they want to cancel actually made a an exception.
Usually, I cancel but I start looking for someone right away to replace, but I made a, instead of canceling. I made an exception and I reduced the price right well since it's organic I'm not running any ads for this one.
I slash the price in half actually. So we went from 400 the week to 200 the week, because first of all it's organic and second, it's Christmas. And third, he's having surgery, so he's not going to be able to do any work, he can only schedule out in January and
So I'm like, can we do that. He's like yeah absolutely we can schedule I can't work, but we can definitely do that so yeah I slash the price in half, 200 instead of canceling it all over and like starting all over and going and hooking someone new.
I thought let me just try this and it worked. And he's like yeah let's do it. Let's slash the price in half, and then we'll reconvene again in January once I recover and pick it up.
So, yeah, yeah, having organic definitely helps in giving you a bit more flexibility of choice with what like options you can provide to them. Yeah. What do you say when someone wants to reduce price but you're, you're running serious as what, how do you, how do you answer that one.
Depends why they want to reduce the price. If they say they don't land any jobs.
Then I say that's on them.
Okay, I try and help them out, but
what is it I've had this recently one client, I set the price like $600 a month just to help them out. And I was like all right we're going to increase prices back up to like normal rate of $1,600.
And he just.
This was all like my fault, because I did this all over text, rather than call them because it was like Sunday at like 7pm, and I knew he had his kids with them and stuff. So I didn't want to bug him so I just sent him like a text message went to bed.
And later on he started texting me and I was busy for like the next two days so it wasn't to like the third day after I got the chance to call him, found out that he was just human pissed off and everything I didn't realize it.
I said look my apologies and stuff I didn't mean any attention like that.
And we've come to an agreement where artists continue to increase the price but it would just be like $100 per month increase each month.
That way, it's not like a massive increase right off the fucking like right off the bat before Christmas it's like a gradual increase that we can work over.
He's still adamant about canceling. I don't think he will, because he relies on the jobs too much, even though he says he doesn't.
But he's one of those stubborn guys that just won't listen when he's like I'm not lending any jobs. And I listen back to the calls and it's clearly he's the problem.
And I've had other like I, I send these calls to other like other clients of mine and I'll say what do you think of this. And they're like yeah this guy sucks like he can't close any deals he can't talk to the customer properly, his communication shit.
He's just, he's just throwing the customer away he's not even trying to help him at all.
Right. Yeah, we're adding more steps I've heard that too like, you know, they they call and you're like hey why don't you send me an email like no, no, that's not.
Don't change the mode of communication. First of all, and second, you keep the ball in your court, don't put the ball in their court because they'll be like yeah screw it I'm not calling them back.
Well go ahead and submit an email with pictures and everything like Are you kidding me, that's not a text message. Send me a text message, your address name and what you need done.
Right, right. So, yeah, that's definitely a factor.
And I like.
I definitely like digging into their sales process.
But also saying hey, the same my business, okay, the same my process, but I'm happy to help and here are some of the things that I see that needs to be mitigated like
you guys that listen do really well, finally, follow ups you can just do to I've never heard from that guy. That's your job for follow up five follow ups until you get something.
But yeah, I definitely see that.
Now tell me about 2025, what do you, what do you got in.
What are you going to start for 2025.
Now I get back up to 40 grand a month. Definitely, and I think have my processes a bit more doled in. I think while I was at that. Yeah, 40k roughly mark by.
I was kind of all over the place. I think I think I had too much going on at the same time, and it was a given that it was all going to fall apart because the foundation wasn't set properly.
Where, as long as I build the foundation up correctly then if shit goes to shit, I would have solid foundation where what happened in that case is I built it up without that solid foundation and everything kind of tumbled over and it's happened before it happened.
And then when I went to zero to 10k I had the exact same issue and going from 10 to 20k I had the exact same issue, where I'll basically go from like zero to 10 and then I'll drop back down to like five grand a month.
I went from 10 to 20 and I dropped back down to like 10 grand a month.
And now I've gone through the exact same exact same issue going from 20 to 40 and I felt back down to like 25 30 ish.
So it's always just to get to that point, realize what I need, and then go back, fix it up, and then go back up there again, and going back up there again is a lot quicker.
The second time around than the first time around.
Right, but I've got no worries about getting back up there getting back up to that scale.
From that learning experience a lot of those sites that I now have they're all ranked organically and they're producing organically, so I don't need to run ads anymore for a lot of those sites when I when I find new clients with them.
So instead of me having to spend the ad spend on it, I've got leads coming through already where they're generating anywhere from 30 to 90 leads per month.
So I can send those straight to someone else in the, in the new, I've been ready to close up a lot of my team to closing up this Friday.
I would pretty much just be focusing on, I guess, building lists out, checking out new areas, seeing what else can be done, creating, I guess, better stops like system operations, and just fine tuning a lot more stuff as well.
What does your operation look like?
Tell me about the team.
So I got a couple guys I got one that looks after like all the backlinking sort of stuff. And then I wrote another one that looks up I would to that look after like all the website builds.
So right now I've just built out a bunch of websites and like the fencing and concreting niche, and I just let them go, and then I just go through and find clients for them.
And then I just run the ads and go through that whole process from there.
You find the hook, and then you run the app.
So, a little bit differently. So I have clients reaching out to me, and then I run the ad, once they pay me.
Gotcha. So that's probably where my process differs from Nick's current process. So I used to do it.
But now I've just, I got clients reaching out to me.
So I'm able to just do it and that's just from Facebook, where they'll just reach out to me from Facebook, say, Hey, look, this is the area.
This is like the niche room.
And how do you get those to reach out to you? Are you running ads on Facebook?
Yeah, just Facebook ads.
Nice.
And you call them, they're in, they want the leads and you're like, all right, I will go ahead and start sending them to you and then that's when you fire up the ad.
So generally, book a call, that 15 minute call is just me qualifying them. So I still qualify them.
And I don't want to, like, I've had people that will book a call and they're just not suitable and I've had to turn them away.
So I'm only having the call when I'm only moving forward with the guys that are, one, I have the area available.
If the area is not available and I already have a client in that area, I'll send them straight over to my client and say, here, this guy needs work.
And they'll just hire them as a subcontractor in some cases.
And that's how that solves their employee issue where they need an employee, but they can't find anyone.
I'm able to send them one of the guys that reach out to me because they want more work and I'll just pass them straight on to them.
So that's happened in a couple of cases.
From that, qualify them and then they go through the process of, we basically jump on a Zoom call and I go through that wholesale script.
I'd say 90% like Nix, nothing fancy. I just, I still have that script up and read off it.
So I'm not, like, memorizing this stuff or anything. I have it off. I read through it.
We go through the process, go through everything, show them what they need to see and then close the deal.
Once I close the deal, I then start up the ads and get everything running.
I like it. So, yeah, that is such an efficient way to do it.
The way I do it is I run the ad, I make sure that I'm getting leads first, then I go hook and start patching over the calls.
I've done enough to do it in Sheets where I know what works, what doesn't work now.
There's well over 200 that I have just sitting there and I now know, okay, this is a good area.
This is what bad looks like and I'm able to tell.
That's the whole point of that 15 minute call is we have a chat.
I get the information that I need to qualify them.
So I find out how much they're making, how many guys they got working with them, how long they've been in business.
They're probably the main three key points that I look at.
But I ask other stuff like what's your goals? Have you done any other marketing before?
What else is there? What services do you do?
So I can find out all the different services they do.
Some might do concreting and fencing.
Some might do fencing and landscaping.
And I find out how else I can help them because it might start off with, all right, we might start off just doing concreting.
Then they might want to expand into fencing.
They might want to expand into bathroom renovations or whatever it is.
And that's where I'm able to sell that down the line.
I sell that idea to them on that sales call where we talk about, OK, it's not just the concreting jobs you get now,
but you get first choice when we start talking about getting the landscaping jobs that come through as well.
So I'm not going to go to someone else. I'm going to go straight to you.
We can start getting you those jobs.
So instead of getting 30 to 40 concrete jobs per month, you're now getting 60 to 70 concrete and landscaping jobs down the future.
Yep. You're stacking them that way.
They never leave. They're getting everything from you, all their business or half of their business coming from you.
So it's really hard to...
And also you're making it a no-brainer for them.
I mean, the price justifies it.
And yeah, they'll never leave. I like that.
And I have stacked deals before.
I have done like stucco and concrete.
I have done paint and epoxy.
You know, the niches that go together.
And that is a great way to keep that partner longer because, you know, you're satisfying two things now, not just one.
And if they...
The biggest thing is as long as you can expand as they expand and you keep up with them.
Yep.
And as long as they expand as you expand as well.
Right. And even if their concrete sucks, but they're still getting a ton of, you know, lawn care jobs, they're like, oh, it justifies it. It's okay.
Yeah.
Otherwise they would have left. They would have cancelled if it was just the concrete.
Yeah, I like it.
That's how it is pretty much.
Like a lot of the clients, they'll do fencing and deck building.
So they'll get heaps of fencing jobs, but then they might only get a couple of decking jobs.
The decking jobs they do get.
Like one client or past client now, I think with like the first month of us sending them decking jobs, it closed like 80 grand just off a couple of jobs.
And that was just in one month.
That's excluding all the fencing jobs.
And I think all the fencing jobs he was doing was like 30 to 40 grand just off the fencing jobs he was making per month.
That's pretty good. Yeah.
I mean, that's another case that he's not going to cancel anytime soon.
He ended up cancelling. Personal reasons though.
Yeah.
80,000 of closed business.
I mean, the thing is that he got me someone else straight away.
So he found me another business and I started working with them.
Once again, young kid not realizing I guess the effort they required in the business didn't last too long.
But now that original client has found me another guy as well.
So I still talk to this guy.
Like I'm still friends with him and everything.
A lot of I'd say probably two of my old clients.
I went out.
I went over to one of their places.
What was it? Sunday night.
I had lunch with their family.
So I'm still like friends with them.
We're still in talks even though he's just gone a different path in his life.
Sure.
Thankfully from that different path,
I used his connection to be able to get my lawn mowing connection,
another like a lawn to mow at an aged care facility.
So we're all still helping each other here.
Wow. Yeah.
I mean, it pays to not burn bridges and nurture those relationships.
You just got an evangelist.
He's like shouting your name from the rooftops and getting you his replacement.
That is as good of a gift.
Yeah.
Cause it wasn't like it didn't work for them.
It's just bad personal issues that came up and they had to take a different path in life.
And that's sometimes it's just what it is.
Like not much you can do about it.
You can try and I've tried doing this in the past is persuading them elsewise,
but sometimes that change is just what they need to do.
In his case, it was, yeah, a lot of personal family related issues.
So he had to just make that choice of, all right,
for the health of my family,
I have to go this route and step away from the business.
Right.
We are.
No, that's great, man.
And you gained a friend and an evangelist like that.
And I've had a similar situation.
Also hooked me up with his nephew because he was retiring.
The nephew didn't do so well.
And then I got another one on my own and a new business on my own.
And that one is working well.
But yeah,
I've been in a similar situation where the guy wanted to retire,
but he didn't want to let go of this cash cow.
And they thought they could pass it on to family,
but the family was too young and too reckless to do anything with it.
Yeah.
It's hard thing is age and stuff,
which sucks because like I'm 22.
So it's basically the people my age and a little bit older,
that at the issues when it comes to running.
That's crazy that you're 22 and you've already gone through, through so much.
I wish I was as seasoned as you are at your age.
I think I was still a student in college, I think when I was 20.
Yeah.
I haven't even done my master's at 22.
I was still a kid or thinking like a kid.
So yeah, I commend you for that, man.
You're dealing with talking with talking to the big boys,
telling the big boys what to do.
That's maturity and leadership for sure.
So great job, man.
22 years old.
I'm very impressed.
Yeah.
I think it helps being in, in that, that trade role, but I'm,
I'm in a trade role with myself as well.
I still got a full-time job that I do want to enjoy.
So being able to talk the same language as them,
I think helps out break down that balance.
Yeah.
Which was just, I think held back a couple of people is they talk
and they just sound like a generic marketing guy that just repeats
what everyone else says.
Right.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean, we're bringing the difference we're bringing.
And I get told that at the end of each and zoom call,
I always ask them,
What made you follow me around and go on with this adventure?
I mean,
What made you follow me around and go on with this venture with me?
I'm sure you get in marketing calls all the time.
You've got guys, you know, promising you leads.
Like what, what made the difference?
And they always say it's the approach that we,
we flipped to the approach instead of promising.
We just bring them the job.
I'm like, do you want it or not?
And it's like a,
I mean,
You know,
We make the decision making easy.
So that's what they all say. They say results in advance.
And they say the, the approach, the way.
You show it.
You don't tell me you show me.
And then.
Yeah, I'll definitely stick with that. That seems to work.
The other thing that I talked about just this morning in another life is.
The way I keep my churn and burn rate low because I have struggled with this
from day one.
People always want to cancel.
Even the people that fall in love with you head over heels, you know,
shit happens in a month later. They're like, yeah, I'm out.
Or their credit card just stops working and you never hear from them again.
So what I do now is I told.
The group in the morning in the life is I always keep four hooks at all times.
If I sell one hook, I have to replace it.
Because that keeps me.
That keeps the standard, the weekly standard.
Because if you lose one hook.
And then you lose another hook. Now you're half now you're 50%.
And then you go get distracted. You lose two more and then boom.
Now your line is empty. Your sales line is completely empty.
And some clients that you closed two months ago are already dropping or six
months ago, whatever.
So keeping those four hooks keeps me accountable and keeps me on task.
Is there anything that you do on your end that, that keeps you.
Qualifying has probably been the biggest thing is the harder I qualify and
the more strict I am with it.
Then the longer they're going to last.
Like if I'm strict and I generally have like a, I got three,
three threes is what I call it.
So they have to be three years in business.
They have to have at least three weeks booked out and have to have at least
three, three guys working for them.
The minimum that I kind of try and go by when I follow that everything works
out like they stick around and there's no dramas.
It's when I, if I fall short and say, oh,
they only got one employee,
that's when they can sometimes be issues or if they got less than three years
in business, that's when they can have issues.
Yes. That's kind of what I go by is those three threes.
Okay. Three employees, three years in business.
What's the, what's the other one?
That's just three weeks booked out. That's it.
Three weeks booked out.
Yep. Yes.
I have at least three weeks worth of pipeline that already exists because if
they've got three weeks worth of pipeline, they start tomorrow.
Like I said, three to six weeks is generally what it takes for someone to
close a deal.
So it means their pipeline is not going to be empty and not relying on my jobs
coming through.
It means they have enough work coming through at the moment that's going to
keep them busy until they start landing the jobs.
Yep.
You are smart Levi.
I think you're very smart.
I'm learning man.
I like this.
Three employees,
three years in business and three weeks booked out.
I mean, I asked you stuff anyways, and I like these metrics anyways,
but I never had them in front of me as a standard.
Like this is the parameters that I need to look for.
Set those standards.
Yeah.
And when they're followed, everything works well.
It's when they're not followed and I try and break them.
It's, it's a, it's a gamble.
It's me gambling pretty much.
And it's something I have to ask myself is, am I willing to gamble on this
person?
And sometimes I'm just like, fuck it.
Let's just risk it all.
And I'll gamble on them.
And it will either work out really well or it won't work out.
And I'm, I'm happy to just gamble it and see how it goes.
Sometimes.
I don't know.
I try and believe in people and give them the best opportunity possible.
And some guys have made the most of it.
Like I said, that guy that pays me a thousand dollars a week.
I always going to go back to this guy because he's just one been with me for
over a year now.
And he's gone through all the different processes.
And it was just start off with him and his brother.
And he was, I think, new to business, new to the area.
He had other businesses, which it's kind of what made me say yes.
But I was lucky enough that I sent him the jobs.
I was down in the same area catching up with another client,
like for a different niche in that area.
And ended up just driving to his house, catching up with them,
having a chat with them,
told them the price then and there and he shook my hand and said,
let's do it.
That was the whole sales process was just me saying, yeah,
it's going to cost you.
Well, I think it was like $6,000 a month.
And he's like, sweet.
Fucking send over what you need to send over.
We'll get everything started when you're ready.
I like it.
I like it, man.
We've already been on an hour.
Let me see if there's any question here.
Oh, hold on.
Luke said, super inspirational.
What you've been able to achieve, Levi.
Well done.
Question.
The question is,
one of my struggles is getting business owners on the hook
because most trades are so busy.
They are not interested in taking the leads because they are booked out
so far in advance and don't need the additional work.
What is your experience with this?
And have you had,
have you still had success convincing business owners to take the leads
even when they are so busy?
Any tips?
It all comes to the end if they're willing to hire more people.
I think.
If they're not willing to hire more people,
then I just call them as they're not a good fit.
If they're not willing to expand their business and they're happy with
where they are,
I don't want to work with someone that's mediocre.
Otherwise I'm dropping my standards down to mediocre level.
I want to work with someone that wants to fucking make as much money as
possible, take everything, control the whole area, expand here,
do this, do that.
That's the type of person I want to work with.
And when I find someone like that,
we work really well together versus if I find someone that,
if I have to hard sell them and just convince them otherwise,
it shouldn't have to be a hard sell. It should be.
I've got more work. Okay.
So the work I've been coming through now is enough to keep my current team
busy.
But if I can double this workload,
it means I can have another team going.
And if I have another team going,
it might mean I can make an extra 30% revenue for my business or 30% profit
from my business.
And it might be an extra 50% revenue for the business as well.
Yeah.
You mentioned a very good, important thing. Keyword.
It shouldn't be hard to sell because the process sells us.
So yeah, that is a great point. If you're finding yourself,
you know, just spewing sales stuff like this is what we do.
We're awesome. And the leads are this.
And that that's a red flag.
Something is not like if you have to convince them and they already have a
customer in hand,
they're probably not a good fit and it is your job not to flip the script on
them. Start putting pressure. Hey,
I don't want to waste your time if you're busy.
The only reason I'm sending you these because you said you can take on more
work in the initial call. If you remember,
you said you can take on anything I send you. And second,
you're running ads. So that tells me you're not,
you're in growth mode. So, so yeah,
you just flip that script on. I mean, like what happened?
Did you change your mind with why you're being, you know,
a whiny little, you know what, right now,
as opposed to our initial call, you're like, yeah, send all of them.
If you're just in for a couple of leads, I totally get it.
I'm happy to send you more. I just need you to have respect for my time the
same way I have respect for your time. I respect your time.
I respect your time. And if this is not for you, I totally get it.
We're all big boys. I would rather go help someone who needs it.
No harm, no foul. We're all brothers and sisters, right?
So that's what I do. If you find yourself,
Paul, I don't remember who asked the question.
Luke. Yeah. If you find yourself in this situation, flip the script.
You don't need to sell yourself. You, you, you set the lead.
The lead is doing the sales for you.
So instead of selling and getting into that desperate position where,
you know, now you smell like sales breath,
flip the script and ask them, has anything changed since we last talked?
Have you changed your mind? Because if you change your mind, totally cool.
I just need to know so I can move on and go help someone else.
And that's when you rattle them a little bit and they're like, okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I didn't say that. I just said that I'm a little busy.
Or they come out of, you know, they come out from behind the curtain.
They say, yeah, you're right. You're right.
I am busy and this is probably not a good time. Great.
Thank you so much for your time. I'm moving on to the next guy.
If this is during like the initial, like trying to hook them, get them interested.
I guess my focus would be finding out like, oh, do you want to hire another team?
If they say no to that, note their name down,
like put them aside because I've called back business owners before like a year later,
six months later, and they're like, yeah, I'm ready pretty much.
And they've said, yeah, some guys don't remember me.
Other guys do remember and they're like, yeah, just it was a bad time.
I was going through this that couldn't go then.
But now I'm ready. I've got another team set up.
Let's let's start this like right away.
Yeah, I asked that too. And then it is in the next script.
You ask how far out they're booked.
And you also ask like a hypothetical question where you're like, OK,
so right now we're not we're not getting any crazy numbers.
But what if we hit like March and we hit a nice stride and now you get double?
Like, what's your plan? Do you have people you can reach out to?
Are you able to hire and grow with the thing?
And that's when they start to project themselves into into that scenario.
Yeah, yeah, absolutely. I have people I can reach out to mark that down.
They have people they can reach out to.
They can grow. They can hire.
And later, if they pull any bullshit on you, you can you can reference it.
Hey, remember what you said last time?
Yeah, well, these people you reach out to. What's that?
And I say to them, yeah, like, what about all these people that you said
you could originally reach out to, like, you know, reach out to them anymore.
What's up in there? Like, it's only been a week.
What's what's changed?
Absolutely. Yeah, I've done that so many times.
Respectfully, of course. But, you know, you got to call it out.
Yeah. And just get the truth. You got to get the truth from them.
They're going to dance around the truth.
Keep anchoring them until they give you that you get your name.
I hope that. Yeah, I'm very straight up.
And I'll just say I won't give you any bullshit from the start
as long as you don't give me any bullshit from the start.
And it was that doesn't really questions it.
They straight up with me.
And that's how a lot of guys are spilt out.
And they said, yeah, like, I've been in jail and stuff.
Like, that's where I got all that stuff spilling out is when I said,
said that little line.
And it helps them relax a little bit because then they know, all right,
if I'm honest, that means he's not going to bullshit with me
and he's not going to say anything.
And I'm going to show them because a lot of my calls are just like discovery
calls pretty much where I still have to do the research to see if there's jobs there.
Nine times out of ten, there is work there.
But I still do that research just to make sure as well.
Yep. No, I mean, they're contractors at the end of the day.
So they are pretty direct and shrewd.
And it is refreshing for them for you to be straightforward with them
because they deal with, you know, uppity calls and, you know, all kind of formal stuff.
And that doesn't jive with them.
So when you give it to them straight, they kind of respect that.
Relax. They're relaxed.
They're not trying to watch their language.
They're not trying to think about what they have to do next.
I know because I'm in that situation where at work, you know, watch what you say and stuff.
But then if you can just relax and say whatever, it doesn't matter.
Yeah. Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah. Sometimes you just got to let your hair down and, you know, show them the real you.
And they respect it. They like it.
It makes them relaxed, too. It makes them comfortable, to your point.
Awesome, man. This has been great.
Over an hour, an hour and 15 minutes. So that must be pretty good.
Let's see if there's any questions. And if there are not, we'll just wrap this one up.
And if you guys have any more questions, you can always drop them in the comments.
Okay. Let's take one last question. If there's one. If not.
Sweet. No, that was it. Luke was the last question. So perfect.
Guys, if you have any more questions for a rock star today, Levi, from the land down under, please drop them in the comments.
I'm really impressed, Levi. You definitely need to pat yourself on the back.
It's been a hell of a ride. And I think you're on to something here.
Appreciate that. Yeah. Yeah. I definitely want to follow up on you because you're firing me up now.
Now you got my gears grinding. I'm going to go and make some moves right after this.
I'm probably going to build a couple of acts tonight because I need that flow. I was going to wait until after Christmas, but I think might as well.
Might as well just dig in. So I appreciate you, my man. Thanks for jumping on.
On an early, such an early hour of the day. And yeah, I will catch you in the group.
We may talk to you then. Appreciate you Levi. See you, mate.